une énième répétition noëlla avait près
par un chignon une réalisation d'une
heure qu'elle travaille depuis le mois
d'octobre pour le style and colour
trophy sur son modèle qui l'accompagnera
et sur sept est malléable
j'aime le challenge j'ai jamais envie de
découvrir autre chose que ce que je fais
a quotidiennement et je voulais aussi à
bas découvrir d'autres talents et
je me dis je suis capable de pouvoir
remporter ce concours alors je me lance
j'ai réalisé un balayage à une couleur
sur mon modèle j'ai choisi de faire le
financement parce que j'aime le travail
minutieux c'est très délicat ça demande
du temps sa demande à l'intention et je
voulais quelque chose de beau et quelque
chose bas de beauregard une inscription
au concours qu'elle doit à son école le
il y à chatou l'établissement propose
chaque année à ses 80 élèves de se
présenter
noëlla est la première à atteindre ce
niveau elle s'intéresse à tout c'est à
dire qu'elle est autant technicienne que
dans la coupe
quand je vous dis qu'elle innove c'est
qu'elle vient changer salon et qu'elle
l'est dans un salon qui est un barber
shop donc vraiment rien ne l'arrête elle
extrêmement volontaire pour noël à c'est
une opportunité de l'inscrire sur son cv
d'en parler de faire un book
et puis pour l'école bien sûr
on mettra ça sur nos sites internet sur
nos réseaux sociaux c'est chouette
d'accompagner une élève et qu'elle
arrive à ce niveau là le 27 janvier
noëlla affrontera trois autres apprentis
dans le concours national
la finale internationale se déroulera en
mars à paris
noëlla espère plus tard ouvrir un centre
de beauté